Hey folks, uh this year at connected
data London, I would like to present our
methodology called meta dot. It's a
methodology using semantic metadata to
connect the dots as the name explains
it. This thing is interesting uh because
we can apply it in life science. This is
our business but also beyond life
science in other industries. The
methodology is using uh different
semantic assets that are uh standardized
along a process that starts uh at
business analysis level and then goes to
business value monitoring when we
deliver solution. The metadot
encompasses the creation of semantic
version of competency question uh
terminology vocabulary then ontology
then shapes uh to solve the use case
then mappings and other standard um
semantic assets. I'm going to present
the methodology from a theoretical point
of view then from a practical point of
view apply to several concrete use cases
where I will demonstrate it end to end.
I hope this can be beneficial not only
for semantic experts but also business
experts especially in life science and
of course to other experts in other
industries. Looking forward presenting
at connect data London in 2026 this